got some movies guys Isabella I have to
ask you did you grow up watching Dora
yeah yeah yeah just like any white you
get hit I was a year younger than the
show and um it was just my life because
she's a bilingual little latina who
loves to explore and I'm a bilingual
little latina likes to explore is that
crazy to think that for some people now
when they think of Dora they'll think of
you that's kind of crazy actually I
think it'll be really really cute when
the kids believe that I'm actually Dora
and they come up to me and give me hugs
like it's already started like kids will
like probably sell me like their
favorite lunchbox or something just for
an autograph it's like crazy
okay kids love Dora yeah yes and I
couldn't worldwide yeah that's fantastic
now your daughter was a fan is that
correct yes um like how did she feel was
she like was she like God dad you're
gonna ruin door for me was she like
really pumped in it no what was she
she's four okay she was three when she
learned that I was gonna do this movie
and she was very excited but she didn't
get it hundred percent she was like okay
and that's it but when she met Isabella
she was very excited to meet her in
person but when she saw a flesh-and-bone
version of Doris you were like kind of
disappointed like that is not my door
she was expecting to meet in person the
animated character what like like a
Space Jam type situation so I don't know
really the O's are walking around yeah
exactly
that's funny no I understand I respect
that but now now she gets it so no
that's that's cute though I would be
like I probably think the same thing
that was very um
so obviously this movie has some awesome
stunts in it it was there anything in
particular that you really enjoyed doing
or maybe you didn't I didn't enjoy
whatever the heck boots look like before
the animated version yeah he was scary I
call them the demon baby because it
looked like boots got stoned and like
actually by like Medusa
and then like someone possessed him and
then yeah it was aversion boots but you
know it was definitely the fever like so
it was scary it was really scary
he's a lot cuter in the jobless be glad
that he looks like that now he certainly
did not but you know but talk about the
stunts everything was really hard to do
I mean we did on our own stunts and it
was very difficult especially the
underwater scenes the the the quicksand
also we all we did all that the rolling
in a log that was recreated as like a
simulation of a log something like a
foam log they made and painted it and
then rolls around in it I thought any
CGI no they they were rolling the roll
the log and we were inside somebody
threw up yeah yeah do you know who no
because the movie so you get out of the
log you turn on a corner and then
there's like a trash but someone missed
the trash and we're like who did this we
don't know this day we think it was one
of the stunt people I was a nightmare
yeah because we wouldn't be able to get
away with it makeup would be like no you
know I wouldn't cop to it either so um
now what do you hope people get from
this film like what do you hope they
like learn from it or enjoy about it I
think it's a very complete movie you're
gonna laugh you're gonna be touched by
this story it's for everyone you can
bring you your toddlers your teenagers
your grandmother your grandfather it's
for everyone
yeah right it's like really creative and
fresh yeah
funny and I think you know if you're
looking for something that's not like
just another cartoon remake a
live-action version of something it's
this is an origin story as well as like
a ten years later kind of different
experience than just like Dora telling
you to say stuff demanding you to say
stuff she didn't even say please and
visual is really beautiful because we
shot in the real real jungle so it's
been yeah
it is stunning